we just finished the meet your character
interrogation process mark work
hypothetical character I came up with
I'm wondering when you do this with
other writers what's the most common
reaction afterwards that they have after
meeting a character okay if it's meeting
the characters like we did with you
where the character comes from within
you as opposed to meeting the characters
when they come out of actors but I'm
going back to what we did with you the
reaction is usually surprised by what
they learned that they didn't know
they're surprised by what the character
says or what the character does or what
the character believes in or doesn't
believe in and a lot of that of course I
have no idea what's going to come up
because I don't know the characters that
well as well as the writer does and I
don't know how they perceive the
character and many times the writer will
perceive the character in a very
precious way this is who she is and this
is what I want her to be it's a very
controlling way so then what'll happen
during the interrogation is something to
come out that is outside of that or
different from that perception that they
have of that creation that they have in
their mind that the character will start
talking in a way or behavior in a way or
responding in a way that they that they
never would have allowed the character
to do as the writer but there's the
character doing it there's the character
saying that there's a character
expressing those feelings those ideas
and they're surprised
so normally then it would be a group of
actors or an actor as this character
Jill or Jack these two characters or
maybe even the grandmother who knows you
know and the writer would be watching
you interrogate those people as those
characters well yes I mean when we get
into the writer life with a writer and
we have a group of actors who are going
to become their characters
it's it's a little more complicated
process because simultaneous
simultaneously I have to
besides interrogating all the actors to
become those characters I have
simultaneously training the writer how
to do this how to the various or the
very beginning steps of interrogation
process and how it can work and then
even then once I've interrogated the
actors to be those characters I will
bring the writer in to start talking to
the characters it won't be just me and
to even get involved in the
interrogation so that's the part of the
meaning I can be interrogating I can be
interrogated and an actress as Jill the
character we just did and I can have the
writer right next to me I could have you
right next to me if we were doing this
and you're the writer
and I can just tap you like go talk to
her and keep it keep up the
interrogation just keep it going and
explore and you may have other questions
you want to ask and and other other
things points of view you want to
express to her to see what's happened so
there's a it's a process of not only
just working with the actors but
bringing the writer into the process and
then eventually engaging them with all
the characters and something that Elsa
mentioned that just for the sake of the
camera I guess we couldn't do is that
I'm sitting in Karin's seat you're
surfers myself in the third person yeah
yep so the lines between Jill and Karen
are gonna be sort of they'd be if I was
standing up and outside of the seat then
it would be more that I'm Jill I guess
yeah you feel you feel more of a
separation right exactly
interesting great do you find that
writers become quite emotional because
they've met their characters sometimes
yeah sometimes they sometimes I'm
emotional because they are responding to
the characters
I guess in a way that they hope that the
audience will that they're actually
meeting them and realizing how
vulnerable they are or how scared they
are or how magnificent they aren't going
wow this is really I'm moved by the
characters and sometimes they'll become
very emotional when something will
happen between two of the characters
[Music]
that they hadn't imagined but actually
is working into the story that they want
to tell it is let's say it's but just
between two characters who have never
met before and suddenly there's a
connection and one character says he
feels that way about the other care
because they'll talk about how they feel
will in the interrogation how they feel
about each other and how they see each
other and sometimes the writer will he
oh my god I never imagined that that
could happen that there could be that
connection between the two and they'll
become emotional because of that because
it's a richness of the characters and
the character relationship that they
hadn't really conceived of yet and then
do you find conversely that they don't
like their character and they don't have
any empathy toward them and there you go
you know what I need to go back to the
drawing board this isn't the character
did I yeah yeah yeah sometimes so okay
that character didn't turn out the way I
had hoped then it would be going back to
okay what were you looking for because
we're basing it on what you told me or
you told us and maybe you need to alter
something along those lines
and we could do it again quite honestly
we could do it again almost immediately
if they say I want to I want to approach
this character in a different way so
okay let's do it talk about it and the
actor can be sitting there listening to
it and say okay we're gonna approach the
character or I'll go to another actress
I'm going to do another actor for that
character and started interrogating them
and interrogate them into the character
again and we'll have a different version
of the character
great yeah I would love to that I mean
that just sounds so exciting even though
I'm not really invested in this
character that I heard this hypothetical
story but just it sounds like really
really fascinating to see this thing
that was in your imagination just like a
very powerful
you